"Shang-Chi and the Legend of the Ten Rings"
is another great trip to the Marvel theme
park.
It's an exciting story full of action and
adventure, but it's more immediately the story
of Shang-Chi coming to terms with his upbringing,
reconciling the good with the bad, and truly
learning to harness the heart of the dragon.
It's also the story of how martial arts, dragons,
and Tony Leung are cool as hell.
There is a lot that happens in this movie
towards the end — a lot of action, a lot
of overlapping set pieces, and a lot of cool
monsters.
So we'll try to break down the ending of the
movie, both a blow-by-blow of the action and
some of the themes.
We're also going to talk about how each of
the three main characters have their own hero's
journey.
Let's begin by talking about Wenwu's arrival
at Ta-Lo.
The citizens of Ta-Lo try to convince Wenwu
one last time that his wife isn't behind the
dark gate, but to no avail.
Wenwu and the Ten Rings start a battle against
Ta-Lo.
Katy is repeatedly denied the chance to join
the fight, being told that she's not ready.
"Oh.
Right."
Wenwu and Shang-Chi finally have a showdown,
during which the father defeats the son and
throws him into the water.
Wenwu makes it to the gate and begins attacking
it, freeing what are referred to as "soulsuckers."
These small, freaky flying creatures start
attacking the village, stealing the souls
of both Ta-Lo citizens and the Ten Rings,
including Death Dealer.
The two sides agree to a truce, and begin
fighting the soulsuckers together.
As Shang-Chi sinks further and further into
the depths underwater, The Great Protector
— likely sensing that Shang-Chi has the
heart of the dragon — awakens.
Shang-Chi comes bursting out of the water
on the back of The Great Protector, with the
dragon eating many of the soulsuckers.
Shang-Chi is dropped off to fight his father,
during which Shang-Chi finally harnesses the
power of the elements.
At this point, though, it's too late: the
soulsuckers have acquired enough souls to
free the so-called Dweller-in-Darkness, an
enormous lizard/dragon/alien who may or may
not be based on the comic character Fin Fang
Foom.
The Dweller grabs Wenwu and devours him, with
Wewnu expressing regret as the Rings transfer
to Shang-Chi.
Shang-Chi rides on the Great Protector, who
takes on the Dweller-in-Darkness.
At one point, Xialing joins Shang-Chi, almost
falling off the Great Protector and telling
Shang-Chi to let her go.
The moment reflects an earlier time in their
lives when Xialing was left behind by her
brother.
This time, however, Shang-Chi says no, he's
not going to lose her again.
At this point, many people have been lost
and the situation has become dire — until
Katy is finally allowed to join the fight.
The Dweller tries to absorb the power of the
dragon, but Katy manages to shoot the Dweller
in the neck with an enhanced arrow.
The beast is finally defeated, and the village
mourns those they lost.
Back in San Francisco, Shang-Chi and Katy
recount their adventure to friends, adding
that Xialing went to her father's compound
to shut down the operation.
These friends, understandably, don't believe
them ... until Wong shows up, makes sure Shang-Chi
has the Rings, and brings them back through
a portal.
The mid-credits scene reveals that the Rings
were a beacon, and Bruce Banner and Carol
Danvers welcome the two to "the circus."
Instead of going back home, Katy and Shang-Chi
take Wong out for some karaoke, with all three
belting out a celebratory "Hotel California."
The post-credits scene reveals that Xialing
did not, in fact, shut down the operation.
Instead, she took it over and now seems to
be training an army.
Her designs at this point are unknown, but
fans are told by a title card that the Ten
Rings will return.
Shang-Chi's transformation is both complex
and simple.
He started the movie as a man trying to move
on from his upbringing, but nobody — especially
people with literal supervillain fathers — can
outrun their past.
By the end of the movie, he has stopped running
and come to terms with his upbringing: the
good, the bad, the ugly, and the beautiful.
He has the heart of the dragon, like his mother
said.
It's not 100% clear whether his father willingly
gave him the Rings or whether he retrieved
them himself, but either way the end result
is that he is worthy to wield them.
When Katy trained as an archer, she was told
that she'd hit nothing if she aimed at nothing.
At the start of the movie, Katy is proudly
directionless.
She revels in being good enough at a dead
end job that allows her to party all the time.
Now she has a purpose — however, she still
makes time for late night karaoke.
Xialing, meanwhile, had to learn her skills
in the shadows.
Her father would barely acknowledge her, much
less train her.
She also learned not to trust people, especially
the men in her life.
It's too early to tell whether she trusts
Shang-Chi again, but now that she's in charge
of something more powerful than an underground
fighting ring, it's clear that she'll never
let women be sidelined again under her watch.
"You're like such a badass.
Everything you do is so cool."
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
MCU movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.